forty thousand people did not assault
the capital okay that's just factually
inaccurate there were maybe a thousand
people that is not making light of the
evil of those people who all will end up
rotting in prison as they should how
many people came to that rally were all
of those people assaulting the capital
is that all marched on the capital and
then the leading they all marched on the
capital it's just inaccurate yeah it
isn't no yes no it is inaccurate malcolm
x ben well you're not mentioning those
mountains we have a terrible habit of
conflating people who do actual violent
activity with a broader rubric of
everyone for example who voted for trump
which was 75 million people and that
really is ugly i mean you've tweeted
about me for example that i'm such a
racist i shouldn't be allowed in
washington dc that sounds rather
authoritarian in an attitude to me i've
never called for you to be kicked off of
msnbc i've never called for anybody not
to buy your book i've never called for
anybody to censor you on twitter let me
tell you something two years ago i was
invited to uh auschwitz for the
auschwitz foundation where they were
holding a conference call lecture me on
the holidays no no i'm going to tell you
what